[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: I'm here to
introduce Dan Levitin.
So he's here today to talk
about his new book, which
was originally published in
hardcover under the title
"Field Guide to Lies," which is
why it was advertised that way.
But the paperback just came
out like this week or Tuesday,
and they retitled it
"Weaponized Lies."
I wonder why?
To make it a little
bit more trendy.
Dan Levitin to talk a
lot more about lies.
DAN LEVITIN: Thank you.
Thank you all.
I'm delighted to
be back at Google.
I want to talk about the current
state of facts and pseudo facts
in the world and perhaps
in the White House.
Well, one of the reasons we
reissued my book in paperback
with this updated title is
what I want to talk about.
I'm beginning to feel
that our country is
in a crisis that could
possibly set us back 400 years.
And I know that sounds dramatic.
And I'm not talking
about politics.
I'm talking about reversing
the Age of Reason, which
ushered in a period of
unprecedented intellectual,
economic, cultural,
and social growth.
The Enlightenment,
as it is also called,
drew a line in the sand
between rumor and fact,
between testable
hypotheses and anecdote,
and between demonstrable
facts and nonsense.
Prior to the Age
of Reason, people
who heard voices in
their heads might
have been burned at the
stake or drowned as witches.
By the 20th century, we had
identified a biological disease
called schizophrenia that
causes these voices in the head.
We've developed
drugs to treat it.
The Age of Reason led
us to the germ theory
of disease, penicillin.
And although it took us a while
and still isn't ubiquitous,
women's rights,
child labor laws,
and a reduction in racist
attitudes around the world.
All thanks to the Age of Reason,
to evidence-based thinking.
But until the last
few months, I think,
it allowed us as
citizens to engage
in a constructive discussion
with elected officials
and public policy makers
about public policy matters.
And these discussions
largely were based on facts,
on evidence that
everybody agreed to.
When I was a kid, if
you ran into somebody,
the proverbial stranger in
the street, somebody at a bus
stop, and you wanted to
talk about the news--
forget when I was a kid, all
the way through my 30s and 40s--
you run into a stranger,
you could be pretty sure
that if you wanted to
talk about the news,
they had the same
news that you did.
There was a limited
number of places
you could get the
news from, and you
might have differed in
your views about how
a particular fact should
be handled or dealt with
or what the best way to
solve unemployment might be
or the best way to solve crime.
But you didn't disagree
about the numbers
underlying crime
or unemployment.
But as you know, the
White House gave, well,
President Trump in particular,
gave wildly different estimates
of the unemployment rate
all in one sentence.
It varied, he said,
between 4 and 1/2% and 43%,
depending on how
you measured it.
Now one of those numbers
is clearly nonsense,
and I think undermines
the ability of us
as citizens to have any kind
of constructive dialogue
about unemployment, if the
numbers can't be agreed upon.
If the current administration
is going to brand as fake facts
that they find
inconvenient, it undermines
the entire political system.
If we're going to throw
out facts as a prerequisite
to discussion, we're
reversing centuries
of cognitive progress.
Now again, I don't see
this as a political matter.
It's not about
Republican or Democrat
or Green Party or libertarian.
And it's not about this
particular White House.
It's about an attitude
that facts don't matter.
And I think they do.
I think evidence matters.
If you're going to
build roads and you've
got a particular county that
you want to put those roads in,
it would be helpful to know
whether you actually need roads
there or not.
Are there drivers there?
Are the roads that are
there not serving us well?
This is the kind of data
collection that many of us
do for a living.
Evidence matters.
The reason I'm calling the book
"Weaponized Lies" is that some
of these distortions
and fake news and things
that we've seen over
the last few months--
first of all, words matter.
I don't like words like
alt-truth or alternative facts
or fake news.
Because I think they're
just euphemisms for lies.
There are no alternative facts.
There are facts, and then there
are things that are not facts.
There's evidence, and then
there's stuff that's not.
Fake news bothers me, because
there's nothing newsy about it.
There's no news in it.
And calling it fake almost
sounds a little too playful,
like a kid trying to get out
of going to school because he
or she is sick, faking illness.
But let's call them what
they are, they're lies.
And these lies have
become weaponized.
In our lifetime, the
original weaponized lie
was the lie that
there were weapons
of mass destruction in
Iraq, which actually led us
into a war.
That's what I mean by a lie
that becomes weaponized.
Or how many of you
heard the story
that Hillary Clinton was
operating a child sex slave
operation out of the
back of a pizza store
in suburban Washington, DC?
Is this familiar to you?
It turns out that this is a lie.
It was traced to a
Macedonian teenager who
made it up just to get the click
through revenue on advertising.
That lie had a million hits.
When snopes.com
and other sources
revealed it to be a hoax,
that story got 35,000 hits.
One of the people
who believed the lie
drove from North Carolina
to DC with an assault rifle
to investigate, and
then actually discharged
the weapon at the pizza place.
Not finding any
evidence, but feeling
that he had to do something.
And so again the lie
became weaponized.
And I think all of us have
to stop and take a breath
and figure out what
we can do to stop
the promulgation of
this kind of nonsense
and I think that's what,
at least in some broadly
writ fashion, that's what
all of you do for a living,
is trying to stop
nonsense and to get data
and evidence into the world.
That's what Google is about.
And I think even apart from
Google, outside of Google,
all of us have a
personal responsibility
as citizens of a free
country to try and keep
the conversation on track.
Now why does any of this
matter to you in your own life?
Maybe you're not political.
Maybe you don't want
to get involved.
Maybe you're just
trying to figure out how
to get by one day at a time.
And I'll tell you
why it matters.
Because evidence-based
thinking in your personal life,
setting aside the
public sphere, it's
correlated with a number
of important outcomes.
Evidence-based
thinking is associated
with conscientiousness,
which is a factor that's
been shown to
correlate very highly
with increased longevity, fewer
health problems, more life
satisfaction.
And in a very real
fashion, being
able to engage in evidence-based
thinking will save you time.
You'll be able to make
decisions more quickly.
You won't have to recover
from bad decisions,
which always takes a
lot longer than having
made a good decision the first
time out, especially decisions
about your health care or
where to invest your retirement
money.
Evidence-based
thinking helps there.
For those of you that have
children or younger brothers
and sisters, this
kind of thinking
will help them get
better grades in school
and to do better on their
papers and assignments.
Non-evidence-based
thinking has actually
had a very dire and
very local consequence.
Just not to put too
fine a point on it,
but you all know that Steve
Jobs died of pancreatic cancer.
What isn't as widely
known is a little bit
of the nuance about the
treatment that he chose.
So when faced with the
opinions of medical experts,
Steve Jobs decided--
look Steve Jobs is clearly
a brilliant man, right?
But he didn't make an
evidence-based decision,
which he later admitted
towards the end of his life.
Rather than go with
traditional Western medicine,
he decided to follow an
alternative medicine regimen,
changing his diet and
getting exercise and things
like that were going to
beat the pancreatic cancer.
Well, by the time he realized
that it wasn't working,
the cancer had progressed
to such a degree
that Western medicine could no
longer help him, and he died.
And he admitted that he had
made an error in judgment
there by not going
with the evidence.
Now I've been a little bit
sloppy with my language
here by referring to
traditional Western medicine
and what he pursued as
alternative medicine.
Because really there's no such
thing as alternative medicine.
I know that I may make some
of you mad by saying that.
I know that Silicon
Valley is ground zero
for alternative health, as
is Marin County I suppose.
I got chewed out when I talked
about this in Nevada recently.
But the way I look at
it, alternative medicine
is a non-sequitur.
It's not like there are
two kinds of medicine,
and one is running in
parallel to the other.
There is medicine which
has been proven to work,
and then anything for
which we have no evidence,
we call alternative medicine.
And then, as soon as
it's been shown to work,
it becomes medicine, right?
Alternative medicine is
simply the category of things
that we have no evidence for.
So just to call it
alternative medicine,
like calling something fake
news kind of elevates it
to a dignity that I
don't think it deserves.
The problem, of course, with
lies and distortions of truth
is that they can lead
you down the wrong path.
And getting back to
the Age of Reason,
it was Voltaire
who said, those who
can make you
believe absurdities,
can make you commit atrocities.
And this is what
I think all of us
need to make a concerted
effort to change
about the way the current
public discourse is going.
Part of the problem,
too, is that there
has been a balkanization
of news sources.
As I said earlier, it
used to be most of us
got all our news
from a few sources.
And sure there was some
crank-- if you went into a city
like San Francisco, and you
went into a Market Street,
there'd be some crank on
the corner with a sandwich
board saying the world
is coming to an end.
Or he might be yelling
into a bullhorn
that there is a terrible
conspiracy, that the CIA is
spreading germs in
the atmosphere to keep
us all docile or whatever.
And you knew because it
was a guy with a sandwich
board and a bullhorn,
you knew it was a crank.
The problem is now those cranks
have turned to the internet,
and it's very difficult to tell.
Because you know, face
it, any 11-year-old
can make a website that looks
professional, as professional
as that of General
Motors or Ford Motors
or a big American company.
And it's harder, because we
don't have the traditional cues
telling us.
I grew up in the
East Bay, and we
had some crank in
our community when
I was a kid who had a little
printing press in his basement
with rubber type.
And he'd print out these
screeds and put them
in front of everybody's door.
And you knew from the
kind of tilty type
and the uneven inking
that this was not
a professional operation, which
didn't mean he wasn't right.
But I believe in
playing statistics.
The statistics are
"The New York Times"
and "The San
Francisco Chronicle"
were more likely to be right
than this guy who was printing
off stuff in his basement,
who might have been right
about things once in a while.
But then sooner or later, "The
Chronicle" would pick up on it.
And then I would read
about it for realsies.
But this balkanization
of the news media
has left us without the
traditional gatekeepers
and checks and balances.
People get their news from
all different sources.
And when they're talking to each
other in the street or online
or through social media,
they're dealing with what
they think are different facts.
I want to clarify there
are not different facts.
There is a set of facts.
But there are
different opinions,
and then there's nonsense
being promoted as fact.
I think that all of us need
to take seriously President
Obama's parting words.
Again, I don't intend
for this to be political.
I imagine that it may sound
political to some of you.
I consider myself to be
nonpartisan and down the center
in most issues.
I think that one of the tests of
the fact that I am nonpartisan
is that I've gotten an equal
number of angry letters
about this latest book
from people on the right
and people on the left, each
of them accusing me of being
a partisan for the other side.
So I must be doing
something right.
So I'm mentioning
Obama not because I
favor democratic
elected officials,
but I think his words were wise.
In his exit speech, he said
that democracy takes work.
That you can't just
take it for granted.
Each of us has to
contribute in some way.
It was his call for
us to be involved.
And Obama wasn't saying
only get involved if you're
going to be a Democrat.
He was saying get involved.
Follow your beliefs.
And I believe that we all
need to be more involved
in supporting three
institutions that
are vital to the future
of our democracy.
One of them is the free
and independent press.
I think we need to support them
by subscribing, by backing them
up when there are
attempts to silence them.
I was gratified to see that
instead of backing down
after Sean Spicer's
first press conference,
the press actually doubled down,
and they're working harder.
"The New York Times"
did a lot of soul
searching about their
failures in the fall.
I know that "The Chronicle" is--
"The San Francisco
Chronicle"-- and I
know that a number of
other publications have.
"The New York Times" issued
a scathing internal report
in which they admitted
to a number of failures.
And as a result, they're
hiring more reporters
with diverse backgrounds.
They're hiring more editors
They're ensuring that "New York
Times" reporters and editors
have better training.
And they're making
an effort to address
voices that might not have been
heard in "The New York Times."
Just in the last two weeks,
"The New York Times,"
which has a leftist bent,
in the last two weeks
I read a pro-life,
anti-abortion op ed,
which you never would have seen
in the last couple of decades
in "The Times."
And I read a pro
Steve Bannon op ed.
Steve Bannon's not bad.
This is why he's good.
So they're making an effort
to address a broad readership.
I think they need to do that.
We need to support
the free press.
The other institution
is the judiciary.
We need to support an
independent judiciary, which
functions as a separate
branch of government
and engages in
evidence-based thinking.
It was no accident,
it was telling
that when the federal judges
reviewed the original Trump
immigration ban, the
phrase that stuck out
was there is no evidence that
these seven countries are
posing a danger to us.
They are evidence-based.
Now the third institution
is science, scientists,
the scientific method.
Scientific method
believes in collecting
data, withholding
judgment until you
have a preponderance of
evidence, rigorously assessed,
peer reviewed.
Now certainly all of you
can complain that these
are imperfect systems.
You know of corrupt journalists.
You've heard about
journalists making up stories.
You've heard of corrupt judges.
You know that there
are corrupt scientists.
In my own field, in
cognitive neuroscience,
we've had two or three terrible
episodes in the last few years
where leading
scientists in our field
admitted to making up data.
Harvard scientists,
we read in the '60s,
took money from
the sugar industry
in order to play down the
bad health effects of sugar.
Yes, there are corrupt people
in all these institutions.
But they're the best we've got,
and they're self-correcting.
They eventually root
out the corruption.
And when they work, they
work to sustain democracy.
Think of judges.
The whole idea of an
independent judiciary
is they're not beholden
to special interests.
They protect the weak
from the powerful.
They protect the
poor from the rich.
They protect people
who might be from under
representative or
disenfranchised communities
from the majority.
That's the way it's
supposed to work.
Again, there are corrupt judges.
There are biased judges.
But that doesn't mean we
throw out the whole system.
Another big point
I'd like to make
is that I think we
need to, as a society,
as a community, and
especially here at Google,
start thinking a little
more carefully about experts
and venerating experts.
There's a kind of culture
in the country right now
of being suspicious of them.
And that has led to the
current climate of fake news
and alternative facts, I think.
And I think we scientists
share some of the blame
here for the fact that
people don't trust experts.
Again, some scientists have
admitted to falsifying data.
The doctor who claimed a link
between autism and vaccines
had his medical license revoked.
His paper was retracted.
He admitted to
falsifying documents.
Andrew Wakefield was his name.
But you still, 20
or 25 years later--
it was 1987 I think,
30 years later--
we still read about
people who are
convinced that there is a link
between autism and the MMR
vaccine.
I'll come back to
that in a bit when I
talk about particular examples.
But I think we scientists
are to blame for not
policing each other better.
And part of it has to do
with pseudo expertise, which
has become kind of a
fascination of mine.
Often times, people
who are qualified
and expert in one
domain will start
pontificating in another domain
that they know nothing about.
And it drives me crazy.
A famous local example
again, William Shockley,
Stanford professor who won
the Nobel Prize in physics.
He shared it with
two other researchers
for inventing, co-inventing
the transistor.
Well, later in his
life, William Shockley,
PhD in physics, Nobel
Prize in physics,
developed deeply racist views
about the genetic inferiority
of a subset of the
American population.
And he went around the
country espousing these views,
and people believed him.
And they must thought, oh, my
god, he's got a Nobel Prize.
He must be really smart.
Well, yes, in physics, but he
had no training in genetics
or genealogy or cognitive
assessment or any of the things
he'd need to know.
And by the way, he was wrong.
But we tended to believe him.
And I'd like to point out
that the PhD in physics
doesn't even mean
that he's an expert
in other kinds of physics.
He was a materials
physics expert.
And I wouldn't have
trusted him to start
talking about cosmology
or about string theory.
Expertise it turns
out is very narrow,
and it's domain specific.
Occasionally, you
run into people
who are expert in
a couple of fields.
But really, when an expert's
talking about something,
you want to be sure
that they are qualified
and that their
expertise is relevant.
There are some funny
examples of this.
How many of you
remember the claim,
hearing the ad campaign,
"four out of five dentists
recommend Colgate?"
Famous ad campaign--
well, it turns out
Colgate got sued for it.
Not because of pseudo
experts, but I'll
get to that in a moment.
I'll make the link in a moment.
They got sued for it because
of what the claim implies.
To the average person, the
court upheld, the claim
that four out of five
recommend Colgate
is tantamount to saying that
four out of five dentists
prefer Colgate.
But in fact, they don't.
Part of critical thinking is
we have to say to ourselves,
what question were the dentists
asked by the pollsters?
Well, it turns out
they were asked
to list on a piece of
paper as many toothpastes
as they like that they
recommend to their patients?
And it turns out they listed
Colgate and Crest and Aim
and Aquafresh and Gleam and
Arm and Hammer and a bunch
toothpastes.
It makes you wonder, what
was that fifth dentist
recommending, right?
That you don't brush your teeth?
Who knows?
But four out of
five-- it was sued.
They had to stop doing
the ads because it's
a misleading claim.
So when you counter
claims like that,
part of the "Field
Guide to Lies,"
the "Weaponized Lies" book
is to give every one of us
some tools, easy to
reach tools, that we
can use when we hear
a claim like that
and know what questions to ask.
So the first question
to ask may not be this.
But somewhere down
the list, if you
hear the result of a
survey, ask yourself
what question do you suppose
these folks were asked.
And if it's a good
report, if it's
in a good newspaper or
a good NPR reporter,
or if somebody has written
a good article on it,
they'll tell you
what the survey was.
They'll reveal that.
They show you what
the questions were.
But getting back to pseudo
experts, the thing that
fascinates me about
this is I'm not
sure dentists are the
right people to ask.
Why do I say that?
I've been going to
dentists all my life.
My dentist has never asked
me what toothpaste I use.
And I'm usually in a
room, and there's somebody
in a room on either side of me.
And the dentist is going around
and visiting three people
at once.
And I've overheard
his conversations.
I've never heard him ask
any other patient what
toothpaste they use.
So why is it that we think
dentists are the right people
to ask?
And who would you ask?
Well, you probably
would want to get
a scientist or a
medical researcher
to randomly assign toothpastes
to a group of people.
And then they use these
different toothpastes
and you follow them
for a few years.
And then you measure various
outcomes of oral health.
Gingivitis, gum
disease, bad breath,
cavities, whatever it is, and
then you've got your answer.
That's a scientific study.
Dentists aren't necessarily
the ones to know.
Shame on those dentists
for answering the question
in the first place.
And shame on the rest
of the dental community
for not pointing
out that dentists
don't know the answer to this.
Now I'm kind of
making fun of this
because there's
not a lot at stake.
Which toothpaste you use
doesn't seem to matter much
according to science.
And the recent report
that even flossing
doesn't seem to matter much.
But it's not funny when
people's lives are at stake.
And there was a
tragic consequence
to this issue of
pseudo expertise
when a young woman named
Kelly Clark in England
was on trial for
murdering her infant.
This was the second
infant of hers that died.
And in testimony,
the pediatrician
testified that the odds of both
babies dying of natural causes
were phenomenally against her.
That she had to have
killed this baby.
That the probability was
very, very extremely,
significantly low that
the baby could have died
other than at her own hand.
So she went to prison
for three years.
The whole time her husband
worked to have her exonerated.
He finally had some
microbiological studies
done of the infant's brain.
And it was found out that the
infant had a congenital disease
that killed it.
Now we believe the
dentists on the toothpaste,
because we think ah,
dentists, teeth, oral health,
they would know.
But they don't.
We believe the pediatrician,
because we think,
oh, infants, pediatrician.
That's a baby doctor.
But most pediatricians
go an entire lifetime
without ever seeing
an infant mortality.
Because fortunately, infant
mortalities are rare.
A pediatrician's not
the right one to ask.
You'd have to ask a medical
examiner, a coroner,
or an epidemiologist, somebody
trained in large population
statistics of
infant death, people
who have seen hundreds or
thousands of infant deaths.
That's the right
person to have testify.
And if the defense
attorney had been
any good in Kelly Clark's case,
he would have pointed that out.
And she wouldn't have had to
spend three years in prison.
Just imagine you're
grieving over the loss
of your second child and in the
middle of the grieving process,
actually in her case at the
beginning of the grieving
process, you're shackled
and taken from your home
and thrown in prison and
then you're put on trial.
It's just horrible.
This is another
kind of consequence
of a failure of thinking
clearly about what's
in front of our very eyes.
I have an interest in
conspiracy theories.
We can talk about that
more later during the Q&A
if you want.
I don't want to
get side tracked.
And certainly I believe
there are conspiracies.
I mean Watergate
was a conspiracy.
It certainly seems
to be the case
that there was some
conspiratorial aspect
to the Kennedy
assassination, if not
the subsequent
investigation of it.
There are conspiracies going
on all around the world
all the time.
But they're probably
not as many of them
as some conspiracy
theorists would think.
And I think that part
of critical thinking
here is that a handful
of unexplained anomalies
doesn't discredit or undermine
an established theory that's
based on thousands
of data points.
And especially, if you're
talking about crime scenes.
Crime scenes are really
messy in a real world case.
And you can't recover every
piece of the airplane.
And you can't recover
every body part
from the people who
were dismembered.
And so you can't have
a 100% investigation.
There are always
unanswered questions.
But if you've got a
well-formed theory that's
corroborated and backed
up by true experts, not
pseudo experts, I think that you
can assume that you're probably
on the right track.
By the way, there are often
many unanswered questions
because the witnesses
didn't see the entire thing
or the witnesses were at odd
angles and different angles
from one another and that
contributes to it as well.
I want to talk about
a handful of tips
that I cover in the book.
I'm grateful to you for inviting
me to talk about the book.
I'll tell you a little
bit about why I wrote it.
I started writing
it in 2001 because I
was charged with the
responsibility of teaching
McGill honors students in
psychology and neuroscience
how to think critically.
And I used a little
book called "How
to Lie with Statistics,"
which I highly recommend.
It was written by Darrel Huff.
It's a thin little paperback.
It's very amusing.
The problem I had with
the book was that most
of the examples in it-- it
was written in the early '50s
or late '40s.
Most of the examples come from
the US Steel Annual Report
from 1943 or the
Coolidge presidency.
And I wanted to have more
contemporary examples.
So I asked my students to
gather them from the media.
And I ended up with
boxes and boxes of these,
and I started
writing about them.
And I'm a bit of
a procrastinator.
So although I started
the book in 2001.
I wrote three other
books in the meantime.
But in 2014, after
visiting you here
to talk about the
organized mind,
a lot of the
conversations I had here
were about the critical
thinking chapter in that book.
And I thought, oh, well,
I've got this old book
on the backburner.
I think that I'll double
down and work on that.
And I wanted it to be a
kind of an updated, "How
to Lie with Statistics," but I
wanted it to be very practical.
No theory, there's nothing
about brain science.
It's just practical steps
that any high school
kid or any adult who's
interested in this
could follow in order to arm
yourself against the people who
want to separate
you from your money
or deceive you or distort
facts for their own means,
their own ends.
It really is a tool
kit that each of us
can reach for that's
simple to apply.
So let me give you an example.
I've already kind of
talked in generalities
about some of them.
One of the powerful things
is to check for plausibility.
Now all you engineers know this.
Plausibility is
usually the first thing
you want to look
at with anything
that has a number on it.
Because the number could just be
ridiculous, and then everything
that follows you don't
have to worry about.
So I was in a taxicab last fall.
And I was working in
the back on my computer,
I have a little internet,
remote internet Wi-Fi device.
And the taxicab driver says,
oh, you're on the internet.
And I said yes.
He says, oh, I just
read that there
are 17 billion people in the
world who lack internet access.
And you know, I'm not really an
expert on the world population.
But the last time I looked, it
was hovering above 7 billion.
It might even have been
as high as 7 and 1/2,
I don't really remember.
I suppose it could have crept
up to 8 billion since I looked,
but I don't think
it's at 17 billion.
That's just not plausible.
So I mean you can throw out
a claim like that right away
with just some real
world knowledge.
In fact, we had a very
interesting conversation
because I had just
visited Google X, where
I was shown your balloon project
which is going to be providing
internet to Africans.
He was very excited about it.
I was very excited
to tell about it.
And the interesting thing
is I didn't contradict him
at the beginning of
the conversation,
because I could tell he
wanted to talk about this.
And I said, you know
it is a tragedy.
There are a lot of
people without internet.
You'd think in this
day and age, internet,
which is the great
democratizing force that
can help raise people out
of ignorance and such,
it should be more widespread.
So we had that
conversation, then
just as I got out of the cab.
I said, oh, and by the way, I
don't think it's 17 billion,
because there's only 7 and 1/2
billion people in the world.
At that point, he was
receptive to being corrected.
My younger self would have
just said, no, you're wrong.
Here's another one.
This was actually published.
The anti-marijuana initiative
folks claimed that,
in the 35 years since California
stopped enforcing its marijuana
laws, the number of
arrests for marijuana--
I'm sorry, the number of users,
the number of marijuana users--
in the 35 years since
marijuana laws stopped
being enforced in California,
the number of marijuana users
has doubled every year.
[LAUGHTER]
For those of you who
aren't chuckling,
these are engineers
chuckling because they
know what happens when you
double a number for 35 times.
And you can do
this just by making
a very simple assumption.
Let's assume that
35 years ago, there
was only one marijuana smoker in
the entire state of California.
I'm pretty sure there was
more than one marijuana smoker
in this very spot 35
years ago, but let's just
say for the whole state
there was only one.
And let's double that number
every year for 35 years.
Well, by the time you get to 35,
you're up at that 17 billion I
mentioned before.
It's not plausible, more people
than there are in the world.
So throw that out, very easy
to do, check for plausibility.
More people died in plane
crashes in 2014 than in 1960.
Therefore, air travel
is at unsafe levels
and you should stop
traveling by air.
It's one of the most
unsafe levels in history.
So plausibility--
is it plausible
that there were more airplane
crashes in 2014 than 1960?
Yeah, that seems plausible.
I don't know, but it
doesn't seem implausible.
But wait a minute, does the
conclusion follow the premise?
Are the data that
they're citing actually
relevant to the
claim they're making?
They're claiming that
air travel is unsafe.
It turns out that,
yes, there were
more plane crashes in 2014.
But there were a
lot more flights
than in 1960 and a
lot more passengers.
So the relevant statistic
here isn't how many crashes,
but how many crashes
per 1,000 miles flown
or how many crashes
per 1,000 flights,
or how many fatalities
per 1,000 miles flown.
Anything like that
that scales so
that you're dealing
with a proportion rather
than raw numbers.
You have to account for the
fact that the world has changed.
So we often find that people,
either because they're
trying to deceive us or
because they don't know better
themselves, will bring
up irrelevant facts.
And a lot of public debate
goes around these kinds of--
well, this is true,
so this must be true.
No, it's not true that
that must be true.
It doesn't necessarily follow.
By the way, for
those of you that
are fans of Sherlock Holmes
and his famous saying,
"deduction, my dear Watson."
Sherlock Holmes does
not engage in deduction.
He engages in something
called abduction,
which is clever guesses
that fit the facts.
Deduction is something
that has to be true
given the premises or the facts
or the evidence that you've
collected.
That's not what he does.
If you look carefully, most
of the time he's saying,
well, I notice that
there is a cigarette
burn on the left sleeve, which
must mean that this person is
right-handed, because it would
be very difficult to burn
your own sleeve
if you're smoking
with the left hand or
these kinds of things.
It's not deduction.
It's abduction.
Another thing I'd
like to remind you
is that averages are
distortions by definition.
Anytime you're looking at an
average, it's a distortion,
and it may not be
telling you all
that you really need to know.
So I could tell you that
there is a room next door
and the net worth, the average
net worth of people in it,
there's 10 people in there,
their average net worth
is $5 billion.
And if you're collecting
for your favorite charity
or you're running a bake
sale for your kid's school
or you're thinking of
leaving Google and working
for a startup, and if only you
can get a little bit of money
going, you're thinking, well,
10 people, 5 billion apiece,
I've got to get in that room.
But you know it could be
nine homeless people and Mark
Zuckerberg, whose net
worth is $50 billion,
and it averages out
to $5 billion each.
The average is correct.
Averages are a distortion
because they don't tell you
all you need to
know and what you
should insist on
having, of course,
along with an average is
the range and some measure
of the dispersion.
Next time you encounter an
average, if those things aren't
reported, the range and
the standard deviation
or some measure of dispersion,
ignore it, because it probably
isn't very helpful.
I think that getting
back to society.
I think that we
all need models of
clear evidence-based thinking.
And they're in short
supply these days.
We need them in the White House
and the courts and the media.
TV shows like "Perry
Mason," when I was growing,
up they showed evidence-based
thinking to a wide audience.
Perry Mason would try a case,
and he'd present evidence,
and then there'd be
some surprising evidence
from the defense or
from the prosecutor.
He was the defense.
There was a prosecutor.
The judge would allow
some evidence and not
other evidence.
Now this was entertainment.
It wasn't an education.
But it did model the very notion
that evidence-based thinking
is a thing.
And it made it look
attractive and sexy.
Whether you were a William
F. Buckley fan or not,
his television show,
"Crossfire" was it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAN LEVITIN: That had civil
discussion between people
who disagreed about
things, and they
stuck close to what the
evidence had to say.
Their viewpoints
might have differed.
But they were engaging in
evidence-based thinking.
I think we need better
models for that.
I'd like to see a
site called, that
mirrors scholar.google.com.
By the way, I've been telling
everybody I know about it.
I don't think you do a very
good job of advertising it.
But I tell people that if
you go to scholar.google
and you're looking for something
about a scientific claim
like is echinacea really
going to help me with my cold?
Or I've just been
prescribed this statin,
and I want to know what
the side effects are.
Rather than searching
in regular Google,
if people search in
scholar.google.com,
they end up getting a much
narrower set of results
that are primarily, as you
know, from the peer reviewed
scientific literature.
And so they're
getting results that
have been vetted
in some sense, that
are much more helpful
than just if you
put in the name of a
drug in regular Google.
You could end up on
the website set up
by the manufacturer of the drug.
And there could be
biases, of course.
Or a site set up
by the manufacturer
of a competing drug who's trying
to get you away from this one.
Or a shill site like
Americansforbett
erhealthcare.org, which really
is run by Pfizer or something.
I mean scholar.google is
this nice independent thing.
And what I'd like to suggest
that Google do, in addition
to scholar.google.com, I'd
like to see evidence.google.com
where you can just type
in anything like sex slave
operation in pizza parlor
or who had the larger
crowd at their inauguration,
and evidence.google
will return just the evidence
that weighs in on that issue.
Both sides, so that the
intelligent searcher,
web user can make
up their own mind.
But you would see,
I would imagine
there'd be two columns, right,
evidence for, evidence against.
And you can see by the
quality and amount of evidence
where the needle tends to lean.
Every time I come here
and make suggestions,
I feel like you're
all rolling your eyes
in the back of your head,
but that's what I think.
Last time I was here,
I said that I thought
that regular Google search--
I had just been
told in the lunch
that I had before I came
here last time that Google
was very proud of the fact that
when they first started out--
well, when you
first started out,
when Google was in a
dorm room effectively--
and you searched Google
in the early days,
you had to scroll
down quite a ways
before you would find the thing
you were really looking for.
And Google has been working
tirelessly of course,
to make the thing
you're really looking
for the first hit on the
list, so that you're not
wasting time.
And there's been a lot
of discussion about how,
because Google knows your IP
address, whether you're signed
in or not, and it knows
your search history,
it tends to tailor
the results for you.
So if I were to search for
something about climate change,
I might get a very
different result
than you get, searching
about climate change,
depending on the kinds of things
we've clicked on in the past.
I might never get
any of your results,
and you might never
get any of mine.
And so I wonder
what you all think
I'd be curious to know your
feelings about how or whether
this has contributed to
this echo chamber phenomenon
that we've been
accused of living in,
this bubble phenomenon that
we're only hearing views
that support our own views.
And we're not being exposed
to what the great promise
of the internet was.
The great democratizing force
was that for once and for all
we could have a free
marketplace of ideas.
You could encounter any
idea that was out there
and judge it for yourself.
But that's getting
harder and harder to do.
And so last time I
was here, I suggested
that Google search should
have like the equivalent
of the hyperspace
button in Asteroids,
where every once in a
while you would say,
I don't want the stuff
that you usually give me.
I want to see something
that's way out there.
I want to see some stuff
that I wouldn't normally see.
Or maybe a little button that
you could enable that says,
I want to see the stuff
you would normally give me,
and I want to see the stuff
that you would normally
give someone else, maybe someone
chosen at random or somebody
who has a very different,
mathematically defined,
higher dimensional manifold
of search history than I do.
And so I'm being exposed
to ideas other than my own.
When I said that two
years ago, people
could not have rolled
their eyes any farther
in the back of their heads.
Possibly because I also
opined that it would be nice
for Google Maps to have a scenic
route button, because when
my wife and I go driving
on Saturday afternoon
to our favorite restaurant.
We don't want the fastest way.
We want the picturesque way.
But I can never get Google
Maps to help me find it.
Again, this is sorry for
the little digression,
but this is Google.
I have the chance to
say what I want to say.
Getting back to my
main theme here.
I think that there are three
institutions that we all
need to support.
That's the take home message.
The free press, the scientific
method, independent judiciary--
I think that we need to
work hard to support them,
and we need to work hard
to do for ourselves.
Frankly, the media can't
keep up with all the lies
that are running around.
They're working overtime.
Fact checking sites aren't able
to keep up with all the lies.
So each of us has
a responsibility,
a personal responsibility,
to figure out what's true
and what's not, to
think for ourselves.
That is the basis
of a free society.
And I think to do that the one
most valuable quality that we
all need, which
unfortunately has
been in somewhat short
supply lately, is humility.
I think we all need a
little more humility.
And I say that
because somebody who
thinks they know everything,
can't learn anything.
But somebody who adopts a
humble attitude that maybe I
don't know everything, well,
then you start asking questions
and you start
looking at evidence.
And you start
seeking out experts
who may know more than you.
That's where true
learning can take place,
and that's where true
evidence-based thinking
can take place.
And I think this comes
down to education.
I've devoted the last
three decades of my life
to being an educator.
And I've seen that
education works.
And fortunately, it works
across the spectrum.
You don't have to have a
high IQ for it to work.
You don't need to be coming from
a high socioeconomic background
for education to work.
It works with everybody.
And the education,
I think, needs
to start with 12-year-olds.
Teaching them
things like when you
land on a website, that's
not the end of the research
enterprise, that's
only the beginning.
You have to ask yourself
who operates the website,
if there are biases.
Who else links to it?
Are they trusted sources?
Use the link tool
in Google search
to see what other
sites are linked to it
and whether they are
reputable or not.
And I think all of
this comes naturally
to us, this kind of
humility and question asking
and inquisitiveness.
Any of you who spend any
time with a four-year-old
at bedtime, knows about
this inquisitiveness, right?
Because you say to
the four-year-old,
it's time to go to bed.
And the four-year-old says why.
And then you say, well,
it's your bed time.
Why?
Well, we set your
bedtime because you
have school in the morning.
Why?
Because we want you to
be rested for school.
Why?
This goes on and on and on.
This is a very natural
human instinct and a phase
that all children go through.
But they have it
beaten out of them.
We have it beaten out of
us by impatient teachers
and impatient parents.
It's often the grandparents
who encourage it.
But I say you know that's a
very natural human inclination.
Asking why is a good start.
Again, I think we need to
take communal responsibility.
And I would like to
recommend that you
don't hit the thumbs
up button on a story
that you read in your social
network, you don't forward it,
unless you've taken
maybe 30 or 40 seconds
to ask yourself whether
it's true or not.
Is it plausible?
Is the evidence that's
being given for the claim
actually was it
relevant to the claim?
Does it come from a good source?
I gave a talk in
England a few weeks ago
and a gentleman said to
me, he says, a lot of us
voted for Brexit
because we believed
this story-- it turned out to
be fake news-- that Britons were
learning losing
350 million pounds
sterling a week by being in the
EU, money that could otherwise
have gone to the National Health
Service, over a billion pounds
a month they were losing.
And he says it turned
out to be false.
But so many of us believed it.
How could we have known?
And I said, well, where
did you read about it?
He said, we all read about
it in the same place.
It was written on the sides
of buses going around town.
I said, did you read
about it anywhere else?
He says, no, but it was
on the sides of the buses?
Well, I said, if the only source
that you have for something
is the side of a bus
or a man on the corner
with a bullhorn and a sandwich
board, it might not be true.
And he says, oh, well, the
media is part of a conspiracy.
And I said, well,
yeah, they are, maybe.
But the media is also
made up of people like you
and me, who are trying to earn
a living and want to get ahead,
maybe win a Pulitzer Prize.
And if there's a
real story out there
they're going to
investigate it, and they're
going to publish it.
And so you're going to get
it sooner or later most
of the time, not to
mention Wikileaks
exposing this kind of stuff.
So you know there is a hierarchy
of information sources.
And I think we need to
be sensitive to that
and rely on it.
It's just statistical.
So thank you very
much for your time.
I'm very much looking
forward to the comments
that you might have
to share with me.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thanks, Dan.
We have a limited
time for questions.
I got one.
Was is the side of a Google bus?
DAN LEVITIN: No.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
physiological evidence or any
kind of study in the area or
in your field to suggest that
there may be physical
differences between people who
can evaluate issues based on
evidence and those who can't?
DAN LEVITIN: I have a couple
of things to say about that.
First of all, there's a new
construct called the RQ.
You've heard of the IQ,
the intelligence quotient.
This is the
rationality quotient.
And it turns out that the
rationality quotient is not
at all correlated with
the intelligence quotient.
You can have people that are
very high in rationality that
have low IQs and vice versa.
Now what I suspect is
going on in the brain
is that people who
have poor impulse
control and poor
emotional control
are more likely to jump to
conclusions than to sit back
and dispassionately let
the evidence come in
before they make an evaluation.
And this could have to do
with configuration differences
in the prefrontal cortex,
the part of the human brain
that's most highly
advanced in humans
compared to other species.
There's also an interesting
link between political party
and fake news.
So it turns out for reasons--
I'm not a sociologist.
So I don't really know
what underlies this.
But a number of studies have
shown that Republican voters
are more likely to
believe the fake news
stories than Democratic voters.
Now it's probably
being driven by
underlying demographic
differences between members
of the two parties.
That in general, Democrats
tend to have better education.
But I mean certainly they're
uneducated Democrats and very
highly educated Republicans.
I'm talking about as a group.
There could be some
demographic differences there.
Republican voters tend to,
although not exclusively,
tend to be in more rural areas
where they have less contact
with a large number of people.
And it's complicated.
AUDIENCE: I was reminded
of some of the analysis
by Noam Chomsky on the media.
And one of his
comments was media
organizations which
are in a sense
far from in a sense
what's going on
tend to be a lot more objective
and stick more to the facts.
And he found that,
compared to American media,
the best media that
he was able to find
was actually in Belgium.
Now presumably if you were
at McGill for 17 years,
you lived in Montreal,
I am a Canadian.
And I read "The
Economist" magazine.
I don't rely on American
media, by and large.
What do you think or can you
give an opinion about how
foreigners view
America events, and I
guess foreign media relating on
American politics in general?
Would you think
that because they
don't have skin in the game,
they don't have a bias.
They don't have a motivation,
that they're actually
more objective and fair?
DAN LEVITIN: Well, I
will answer the question.
But first I'd like to say that
I am not an expert on this,
and I don't want to become
a pseudo expert here.
I don't have expertise
in media studies
or communication or sociology
or political science.
People in those fields might
have a better bead on this.
I can speak as a private
citizen, just my own views.
By the way, you may
say, well, what's
a neuroscientist doing
talking about statistics?
I am a member of the American
Statistical Association.
And I've published papers
in statistical journals,
and I've taught statistics.
And I had 40 members of
the American Statistical
Association review the book
before it went to press.
So I've been trying
to be very careful not
to become a pseudo expert.
I think that certainly there are
some great foreign newspapers
and magazines and the
BBC, great news network.
I think that we
don't all have time
to read six or eight
newspapers a day.
I think you can just
choose one that you
like, for whatever reason,
or two, or broadcast news.
And stick with it.
And just figure that
the major stories
are going to be reported there.
Now a news source based
in Belgium or in London
may not pick up on the fact
that the Orrville Dam was
about to collapse or
that the water table here
in northern California
is finally restored
after x years of drought.
But the big things
they'll get, and if you
want some local color, you
read "The Mercury News"
or something.
But I don't know whether they're
more objective because they
don't have skin in the game.
AUDIENCE: Most of what
you said about arguing
for evidence-based reasoning
and advocating for the media
and judiciary and science
sounds pretty reasonable to me.
What kind of
objections do you get?
Do people object to these ideas?
DAN LEVITIN: Yes,
they do vehemently.
They say evidence-based
thinking is just
for a bunch of
Poindexters and egg heads.
And I don't trust you people.
You people have kept people
like me out of the workplace,
or I don't have the job I want.
Or I'm only working part-time.
And you coastal lefties
talk about evidence,
you know, well, I
don't have a job.
You scientists can't
make up your minds.
Every time I pick
up the newspaper
to figure out what to eat,
I hear a different story.
And so, if I can't trust
you about that, how can
I trust you about anything?
And I read that
three scientists who
were saying that
climate change is real
were being bribed to say it.
So I can't trust any of it.
I'm just going with my gut.
That's one of the
big objections.
And the other objection I get
is that there is a conspiracy
and that I'm part of it
and I'm being paid off.
And I suppose, but
I don't think I'd
be driving a 10-year-old
car if that were true.
I actually say that.
I say, come with me
to the parking lot.
I'll show you my
10-year-old car.
And they say, oh,
well, you probably
have a fancy car in the garage.
You can't win with a
conspiracy theorist,
because there's always
some other level.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks for coming to
talk to Google, and thank you,
Dan.
[APPLAUSE]